to welcome everybody to the world
famous h3 podcast i am your host ethan
klein the fresh prince of dead air
7.1 yes i'll say that again yo 7.1 out
of 5 on wikifeet if you make turn that
into multiple of 10
if that was like out of 10 you'd be
looking at a 14.2 out of 10
on wikipedi ela your thoughts my co-host
dilo
hi um uh yeah that's pretty nice pretty
impressive thank you very much
good luck ethan thank you keemstar
today's episode is sponsored by
harry's bright sellers and keeps
quickly there's also a new teddy fresh
item
out today that i'm very excited to
present to you
ironically out of this whole month's
drop this item in the
in the um banner which is like the ela
client original is not out yet
ironically it is ironic
welcome to um living through a pandemic
there are delays all the time it's not
shade i'm just saying
people are probably wondering where it
is hated me did i
no which it's just the most interesting
piece and that's what we wanted to put
in the banner
and so when does this come out when is
this one coming it was supposed to come
out today but there's delays so
we don't know it's like any day but
we're kind of
it's unknown it's a fire piece though
but no i mean no shade obviously i mean
you know
hey come on it's out of our control i'm
sunning you i'm lighting you i'm
blasting you with life
you almost with peace and loved me no no
no no no no
i would never never never i am sun
beaming your ass anyway
this is the piece that's out it's in
love no no no no no there's no peace and
love here
it's funny he's like that sounds like
bad no peace and love no
no no no you know what i mean
it's such a horrible thing to wish for
peace and love how dare you
anyway this is what happens with peace
and love i am warning you
no peace and love this is a patchwork
pastel knit zip up folks out
now um it is really nice i
look at that oh that's hot that is hot
so anyway that's it that just came out
someday the elo climb will come out and
we'll let you know
okay when we start this show
i want to do something that shows my
serious commitment to weight loss
and so we have conceived of the idea
of the first ever h3
weigh-in ladies and gentlemen
i feel like you've definitely done that
before
so it's not in i've never weighed in
have i
you definitely did what i've never
weighed in how dare you take away from
me did you just peace and love me
okay you ready dan okay so
just to preface this i have
eaten breakfast and drink coffee and had
water and i'm wearing a lot of clothing
so it's not a great weigh-in but all we
have
is a scale but we have a place to start
so that
when next week i come and get on the
scale again we'll have some place to
compare
this is the keto diet ladies and
gentlemen one weekend just staring at us
one week in 40 pounds 1 foot
40 pounds one week into the keto diet
okay now before i step on the scale just
one more time i just want to explain
that this is not my true weight this is
gonna be higher than my true weight this
is a visual dead air
just saying now okay here we go
okay i am stepping on the scale
that is higher that's a lot higher than
i thought it would be
what's the number jesus christ
that's a lot higher than my scale said
in the morning
it's like what do you call that like 231
232
see that's that's [ __ ]
[Music]
yo i weighed in this morning in the
morning naked and stuff before eating
at two i think you should come back here
because this
just triggering me
it's triggering you imagine how i feel
well you're fat yo what how is it
showing me 232 that's some
zack what the [ __ ] how much is your
shirt weight
i don't know it looks heavy it's a
rigged
[ __ ] skill man i'm not too i'm over
to that
maybe this scale is just different yeah
i mean it's different it's an analog
scale maybe it's that's the most
wouldn't analog be more accurate maybe i
really don't trust it man it's fake news
don't oh this is just so depressing
well i i think it's not because
you are you technically probably weigh
less
probably i don't know i got a little
cube in my mouth and then
i wonder if i wanted to commit to eating
it or spit it out
um well okay write it down dan
three let's just say oh three no two
thirty two
i mean i'm gonna make your weight loss
more epic and as long as we use the same
scale it's awesome yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay that's humiliating
i swear i was in that i was in at 2
22 this morning how i gained 8 pounds of
clothing and
like water that's not possible is it it
was two to two
yeah two to two because i'm gonna wear
dyslexic
and you might no it was two two two
because i kept weighing it at 225 was
like my starting place
so it's like wow wait i lost four pounds
this week
because i've been on the keto committed
for a week
so i think it's just as scary and
apparently i just gained
ten pounds i'm eating mcdonald's
no no no scale issue
[Music]
and it will be fine okay
i mean it's just something to get on the
i'm getting in on the dieting with you
ethan i'm doing the chet hanks
diet plan what's the dead chet hanks
shout out to the island fitness plan
what is the chat diet bun
i don't really know what the plan is
but every day he posts
hashtag 60 day challenge and then it's
him doing
some sort of exercise oh you are you
doing that yeah
outlined he hasn't outlined what it is
how often it's just
60-day challenges so you're doing the
6-10
you're doing the challenge yet you don't
know exactly what it is but you are
doing it
yeah i mean i'm on day i'm on day three
what did you do the first two days
i just did like various workouts i
haven't eaten any sugar or anything oh
good for you keeping it clean
you inspired me but you don't need to
lose weight love me
daddy no he's got this you're trying to
bulk
yeah he's [ __ ] he's getting in a
little more shape you know
i want to do that too 60 day challenge
chad hanks walk one
i started to get worried my stomach was
gonna get like
old lady floppy so
i'm uh i'm starting to do
oh he's sitting here on two coffees like
damn
no it's serious oh it is thank you [ __ ]
them ross [ __ ] them
ross i'm starting to do your stomach and
not flop me man
i also started doing 20 squats a day
where are you doing squats
just like before i go to sleep damn girl
tighten that ass up
hell yeah i didn't know you were doing
squats yeah that's my
ela climb program yeah oh i love that i
just didn't know i'm just i'm it's not
that much i've got their own program no
i'm just happy that you're
you're doing something i'm just i feel
like i am
old and i feel like i got up well listen
first of all business of prevention
right now right that's what benjamin
franklin you say an
ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
solution
really huh prevention is worth way more
than
trying to fix it once it's broke
benjamin franklin ladies and gentlemen
that
was abraham lincoln it all started with
me noticing a wrinkle here
yeah and i thought i just slept like and
it was like just it was gonna go away
just like a pillow crease or something
and it hasn't gone away and i was like
oh wow okay let me get a look at that
wrinkles are a thing
this wrinkle has been living in ela's
head rent-free this wrinkle
it's like there isn't there edgar allan
poe poem about how he like saw
one little oh yeah he kept like hearing
that beating heart
and the floor that's like the wrinkle
and it kept driving him mad trying to
get to the beating heart
something like that i think you look
beautiful you have not aged
you have not aged you do not age you are
age-defying goddess
you are beautiful perfect but i'm happy
you're getting in shape
but i do have to break it too we are
getting [ __ ] i'm about to be 36
bro
[Laughter]
bro i see some 36 i see some people on
tv who are like 36
i'm like that guy's old as [ __ ] and then
i find out he's 36 i was like
yeah i get scared for a minute
yeah i know i'm not like the most
gracefully aged person but
well people always think i'm fifteen
right people think i'm 50 years old
sometimes
but i've seen some 36 year olds out
there who have [ __ ] been through life
i've always um i always say
that i like your gray hair and i don't
think it makes you look older i don't
get that i think it's cool
thank you bro once we're 50
though i don't know i don't really care
about aging that much i just don't want
i just want to
i just want to do what i can do now like
prevention yeah prevention exactly
aging doesn't really scare me no it
doesn't really scare me i'm not
i don't think i would ever want to do
like any botox or any
whatever i went to a dermatologist for
the first time
because i figured like i don't have a
skincare routine like you you go on
youtube
everyone's like here's my skincare
routine yeah it's been like i don't have
a routine i don't know what to do so i
went to a dermatologist
and um and he was like well here's what
you could do and
he prescribed to me like this whole
skincare routine
and then he was like also in the beauty
world what you could do is like
and i was like oh no no no oh you
started trying to pitch yeah cosmetics
it was like you have like really light
uh thin skin and what you're probably
gonna need is like
and it started to show a little lift and
i was like i don't think i even looked
better when he did that
like i don't know that he's pitches that
too like i guess you went to a plastic
surgeon though
they do it all so because it was
recommended to you by a friend who
uses his services in that way as well as
well as other services they do it all
yeah
let me get a look at you so what we're
going to need from you is just a little
i love video we're saying like in the
beauty world i'm not from the beauty
world
yeah if you want to join the club
don't ever you don't need it i i i
honestly feel with peace and love
people do whatever they want to feel
better but maybe maybe the people who do
it good i don't notice but
right i feel like when people get start
getting these anti-aging surgeries they
look older like i swear to god i've seen
i've seen
yeah i kind of feel that way too oh
marrying millions i started watching oh
my god
you guys oh this show is off the rails
has anyone seen that
mary we just watched the first season
one
there's this one girl who's obviously
very beautiful
37 only two to one and a half two years
older than me
and she just has so much surgery you
could tell she's a beautiful
youthful woman but she's so much surgery
that i thought she was much
older it's clear that she got this
surgery to prevent aging but
i was shocked when i learned that she
was only 36.
but i think for some people they're just
into that look
yeah so it's like trisha says she wants
her boobs to look fake as possible
exactly so it's just i guess at the end
of the day like a taste
and preference um thank you
you're welcome tristan i don't know what
i'm what um
i remember when um everyone wanted to do
plastic
boob surgery to make it look natural
that's right now a lot of people want it
to
that's i don't look fake that's like a
porn thing where people are like i
i personally don't get what do i know
dude yeah i thought the point was to
make it look natural
daddy do you zach i'll ask you because
you're kind of no
in the know all this do you prefer to
look fake or natural
or do you understand the fake look um
i guess i prefer the natural look right
yeah that would be uh that's my cup of
tea
okay zach is the professional
he's the when it comes to weird sexual
things he's our go-to man
sexpert
oh did you see this thing a b cent i
might have some good news for you
what do you think he's saying he's
saying uh the scale was affected by the
fact that there's carpet down here
okay what i would what i wanted to ask
you wait what
what i wanted to ask is dan do you
approximately know your weight
i know my honestly so step on that step
on that but i'm wearing clothes
well so just just step on that and tell
me if you think it's in the right place
or if it's
weighing you heavy i think abby's right
i think the carpet is definitely
impacting yeah but how's it gonna add
it seems right oh brother dan can you
step on there and give me an idea if
it's right
i don't really even know my way you know
it's kind of scary
i haven't been on a scale in years all
right i won't do that to you i know
i know traumatic it can be i've avoided
scales
almost my whole and thought adult life i
i've i've never owned a scale so i
i honestly don't know like freddy
krueger like i have [ __ ]
they're scary man it's kind of a curse
like maybe we shouldn't even have it in
the house
throw all skills out kind of like small
scale you should have an umbrella and
shouldn't open an umbrella inside the
house or something maybe we shouldn't
have scales
really that's what you would tell
that person you're like listen baby we
don't need scales in this house
just be happy i mean it's stressful for
me too because i hate when i go on it
and i see that i lost weight
no i want to stick to this i want to
hold myself accountable
you tell me that didn't weigh you heavy
no
and i mean while while it is carpeted in
here uh
it's like incredibly thin carpet like
the thinnest carpet you could have so
it's probably not
listen the carpeting adding 10 pounds to
my fat
look you got to give it more time man
yes
okay okay yes yes yes
okay i get it thank you
[Laughter]
[Music]
i'll give it more time i guarantee man
again
i'm giving it more time you got the zach
guarantee yeah i got the back guarantee
huh
does he get a refund if uh no results
do you like the gorilla glue your
[ __ ] eyebrows
sure thank you exciting do you feel any
lighter
no i don't look different either but i
swear to you i've been
so i've been so good i've been so
dedicated and so good
i've been exercising and i've also been
like
not eat like trying not to eat two in
addition to being keto i'd be like i'm
gonna eat try to eat less calories too
i've been doing everything as good as
possible do i feel skinnier
no do my sk does my clothing fit
looser no do i look thinner
no do i feel better no i don't know that
it's
true that you don't look thinner
actually i have to disagree with that
well i
okay thank you yeah i think it's working
i think you just need to chill
i've given it time when did you start
you started like last friday right it
hasn't even been
a week yet no i started a week ago daddy
i i did notice in the frenemies episode
your stomach did look
a little reduced yeah i know i i think
you are looking less
big bigly
all right so yadda yadda oh
okay so and then ila you wanna we're
gonna give an insemination update
so i asked the doctors and i feel
like just a just a preference we're
talking about turkey basting
ila with my semen
we talked we touched on it last week so
we're doing yeah ethan always finds a
way to make everything sound like the
worst thing
possible um so
either got ela got all paranoid which i
would love because i didn't want to be
the one to have to ask this but she goes
can ethan stay with the semen so
like the nuclear codes bro you got to
stay with it yeah i asked them about it
and the doctor said that first of all
for the purpose of no mistakes happening
they only
process one case at a time from
beginning to
the end of the process so it's not like
they're gonna handle you and another
person
and that might get mixed up they don't
even
go there on purpose so how does that
prevent like the baby god
from chizzing in the cup because
when you hand it to the lab it's like
there's people that are
doing they immediately start to i know
they clean it i don't know what they
do i mean it's not like there's a point
in which someone takes it
into the bathroom well what if he's in
the lab and then someone walks out and
he just nuts real fast in it
i really don't think that's gonna happen
but i did ask if you could be there and
they said that
it might be they said they said nobody's
ever asked no one has ever asked that
but that it's possible i was like oh
but i feel like this is because the only
way i'll trust it a little bit like to a
conspiracy
thing i don't know i feel like i want to
do it i think it's fine
i agree that i agree i know i'm being
overly paranoid but i'm just saying like
i just didn't want to have any like
thoughts like that
was thrown around my head you know when
you're it's a little paranoid but it's
it's not without precedent i mean
some people said like what exactly are
the
details of what happened there because
for example it can happen when like
the process is a little different like
in our case i don't think
that it necessarily happens that much
yeah and i guess that's
that story of the baby god that place
was a um like a sperm
bank kind of place exactly it's
different that's how conspiracies are
born well i
if you like a little bit of truth a
little bit of fear
and boom there's a conspiracy this isn't
a full-blown conspiracy i'm just
fine but i don't want to become that
person it's like i feel like the doctor
is legit
it's a nice i'm just asking questions
bro it's fine and i go ahead and hit him
with the 911
doc what are you waiting for i ask the
questions
and i feel fine i think i agree i'm with
you
that's it i want to be in the room
in the lap not in the cup hand it to
them
you know what i mean and then from there
to your room
now you're living i want to be there the
whole time to watch the change of
command
okay wake up you may not want to be
there because apparently it takes uh
hours i'll be there okay because they do
one person at a time
also if there's no guys there i'll feel
better like guys are weird like bro i
know that if there's a dude in there
he's going to jizz in the cup
100
he probably has a bag of jizz in his
pocket that he just dumped in
now you're living just saying it's weird
out there
but i agree we should do it all right
so we're gonna do it that's the update
yeah now are we gonna talk about the
elephant in the room aka
the rolls-royce in the room yeah i got a
rolls-royce
[Laughter]
so this if you guys saw the new
frenemies
you'll know what we're talking about but
we did the athletic competition
and trisha first of all blew me away
with her athleticism which
should be concerning to you
is it a compliment to her or a concern
to me concerned to you
really wow thank you
well i agree i mean yeah i'm concerned i
am concerned
i mean she kicked my ass in a lot of
categories like
jump rope i thought you used to be good
at that sit-ups she like
she like the jump rope wasn't a blowout
you were able to do the double jump she
couldn't
yeah but like endurance-wise but she had
this different technique where she was
doing these little hops and going slow
and i was jump roping faster i think it
was a technique issue but anyway she
beat me
the one that really shocked me
by the way she didn't get close to doing
a pull-up because that was like the
debate that started it she couldn't even
lift herself up a little bit
yeah that's hard but she started i was
doing we were having a plank competition
which is when you're on your elbows and
you go
straight i can do a minute
you do a minute right now okay do it
right now
sure let's put on the timer i have a
camera
here let's get you on the scale let's
get you on the scale cam
all right all right ela says she can
plank for a minute let's see what she's
got
i'll time it so anyway i was doing a
plank and i made it you know like 20
30 seconds i was like i'm over this and
then trish is like i can do a minute i
was like there is no way you can do a
minute there's no way
and trista's been trying to get me on
the uh
to get me a mat can they hear me dan
they can hear me right
trish has been trying to get me a
matching black rolls royce since the
start of the show
and i said if you could blink for a
minute i will go get a rolls royce right
now
i thought there was no chance she could
do it
and she did it right before my eyes she
planked on my ass
for a minute and so true to my word
of course trish was like i know a guy i
know a guy
okay you ready you just took i got it i
got my timer out
what you don't trust me to time you well
okay
jesus trust issues
all right all right come on it's just
wires don't make excuses
all right ready in three
two one all right ela is planked
she is in a pretty good stance here
power stance
nice music zack loving it how are you
doing elo
you have the mic here let me get you the
mic
[Music]
uh we can't hear you
okay it's on now ela how are you feeling
we're at uh uh
40 seconds shaking she's quivering she's
obviously in a lot of pain elo do you
want to comment
no how much time we got dan uh
shredder is licking either space
shredders in her face 10 seconds
[Music]
okay
[Music]
yeah look at you though you're dying you
barely made it
that was a close one but we but you did
it i'm proud of you i'm impressed
try doing it with 100 pounds on your
stomach
well you but i mean look
i have no excuse on treasury she's got
like
a lot i mean she's got just a lot of
yeah
i mean her boobs alone she said weighs
like a 100 pounds
good job
so she did the play i'm impressed you so
did i get another rolls-royce
yeah yeah okay right whenever people win
i buy it myself
so she says she gets on the phone she
goes i know guys so she gets this guy in
the call
who sold her all her cars he goes yeah i
can get you one he said he said we need
a black on black
he says there's one in san diego we'll
drive it up on a truck right now
literally on the phone i haven't even
been in the dealership
i haven't even seen the thing he sends
me a link i say that's fine it's black
whatever
2019 slightly used at like 3 000 miles
and i said um it looks fine
cool so literally a few hours later
i'm i i didn't see it i didn't even talk
to him i put him in touch with like our
our business manager who took care of
everything and i just showed up and got
the [ __ ] rolls royce in a day
daddy that was wild
and then we just went straight to in and
out and i got a protein style
i love it it's a horrible financial
probably the biggest financial
mistake of my life
[Laughter]
yeah the trade-in cost us money because
we were upside down because
the porsche we had for one year of three
and we owed money so we have to pay them
twenty thousand dollars to take the
porsche
yeah it was a horrible deal that
actually the trade-in cost us
big time so we traded and he was born
but also it seemed
so impossible like the whole day it just
seemed like there was no way it's gonna
happen
but ethan and teresa really wanted it to
be like same day for
for the it all to happen in one episode
well he's like i don't know if we could
get it up from san diego and i was like
look dude i'm just going to be real with
you
with peace and love i'm probably not
going to want it tomorrow
i'm just saying i'm probably not going
to want this tomorrow just being honest
like if you want the deal to go through
like we should probably get this done
today
so he's like all right even just
figuring out how to pay them was a
whole big deal and well there was like a
huge down payment
and are cr they're like we need it on a
credit card and so i had to call the
bank to increase my credit card limit
but i couldn't do it
in one day and then i called to do the
debit card and the office was closed
so then we had to figure out like okay
i'll give you partner check give your
partner a credit card and then tomorrow
i'll send you a wire for the rest like
you know what i mean
yeah it was crazy and then we hit like
all this [ __ ]
and then we got it done though all right
so we're ready to come in
and come with the porsche and i was like
oh [ __ ] i gotta empty my car like this
is crazy
by the way ela sacrificed her car to me
that was her gift to me
yes yeah because nathan said that
it's never really a good gift for me
which is such [ __ ]
you took that really hard yeah because i
think i want to be a good
gift giver i like to give gifts to
people it's not your fault i
know but still i'm not mad i know but it
still sucks
well you gave me a beautiful gift the
other i mean was it yesterday no the day
before
is that what we're talking about yeah
yeah yeah
that trade-in was so brutal though like
we literally had to pay them 20
dollars just to take the [ __ ] car off
right because we had two years left on
the lease
oh brother this was such a mistake
i love the car though it's pretty crazy
i still can't believe it i i like i
don't know what to think about it it's
like it's a rolls-royce some of the
features what are they doing in our
driveway
we cut out some of the stuff um uh
at the dealership or whatever uh that
only the the members saw
but one of the things that blew me away
is the um
umbrella built into the door oh yeah
that's the [ __ ]
so there's another so on the back
passenger sides
doors there's an umbrella in both the
doors and then
apparently if the umbrella's soaking wet
you can still put it back in the hole
because there's fans in there built to
dry it off
is that car a v8 or is it a 12 cylinder
bro i have no [ __ ] idea i'm like are
you kidding me what's it called again
what's like the model
call again rolls royce coal again
it's always saying that wrong i could be
pulling again pulling in you're
the suspension on the car it's all
german engineering too so
um
yeah it's a what it's a v12 it's a v12
jack
that goes yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just
it's all uh
better vv whatever the top v is it
better be that it's a big ass engine
yeah i still feel very surreal
i don't know um i don't know if i can
even drive it yet
i haven't really processed
i haven't tried driving it yet i'm
scared
sorry and then trisha was ready to buy
another one while we were there i was
like girl please
she's like oh i want this one i'm gonna
come back tomorrow and get her i was
like please
and then the sales guy was there like
yeah let's do it and i was like no
no no well don't be stupid
i remember the first time i came here to
the
states was the first time i saw a
rolls-royce here in l.a
and i was like i really had to stop and
take a good look at it i was like oh my
god this is like the most beautiful
thing
now you're in one girl in the world
that's
getting pregnant in that car
i'm just kidding i'm getting pregnant in
the in-n-out parking lot girl
gross
so i mean i haven't even driven it that
much we went on a long drive
yesterday just kind of go putts around
and see how it feels
feels great it was fun
it's huge heavy car like if i get an
accident i ain't dying there
that whole family is [ __ ] dead
things are boat dude my can you see the
weight on it
yeah it's uh 6069 pounds
is that a lot yes it's a heavy car
so how much is like a tesla yeah how
much is like a tesla model x
tesla x it's probably because it's
electric it's probably
i would imagine really light actually
uh let's see let me know i
don't know actually no i'm wrong that's
uh 5 000
to 5600 pounds so it's actually a pretty
heavy car too and how much i can see how
much is the colon
electric batteries are pretty six
thousand
okay just let me know which cars are
heavier on the road to so i can avoid
them in a
collision
[Laughter]
i want to know which cars i can destroy
on the road your car is probably like
five the weight of like five of my cars
so please don't hit me
okay just let me know which cars are
close in weight just so i can avoid them
on the road
a semi semi truck okay good to know
stay away from hummers yeah homer
anymore i literally don't see homer's on
the road ever anymore that's true
forever i always hated hummers
really because they're just like it's
like okay dude
carson is teenager but i mean yeah i was
a teenager
avoid uh range rovers uh oh the tahoe i
can [ __ ] up a tahoe
five thousand six hundred minus six
thousand right yeah you can [ __ ] up at
the top high tahoe
see in the [ __ ] bottom of the lake
the range
we got to stay away from them
all right we're uh we're at 33 minutes
oh we barely got anywhere
all right we're going to take a break to
thank our sponsors when we come back do
you want to maybe cut that
it's a little ridiculous yeah i mean dan
can cut it if he wants he could bleep it
this is the reality of who i am i mean
we can't whitewash this is not beautiful
this is not nice this is it
we're going to take a break to thank our
sponsors when we come back
ian and the gang has put together a
special
segment for our enjoyment and pleasure
ian
do you want to maybe set it up a little
bit for before the break
we're talking fashion
the guys put on a fashion show yeah
you guys have like pitches for teddy
fresh right or something like that we
got a couple
hmm exciting
okay then so uh we'll be right back with
the fashion show
[Music]
all righty we've got today thank you to
bright sellers bright settlers is the
wine subscription service that helps you
find wines you love
while making wine more accessible to
everybody
by taking their 30 second quiz bright
cellars will pair you with
six unique and personalized wines
shredder what are you doing here
you want to be in the shop come here you
want to do the brian the bright cellars
shredders out of control right now it's
important to stay healthy and at home
when you can
bright cellars allows you to skip the
store while still
personalizing wine right to your door
you can skip an order whenever you need
bright sellers delivers based on your
schedule
you can always change the amount of reds
and whites you receive if you are a
seasonal
drinker what's great about bright cellar
is that each box offers a unique wine
experience
that includes a wine education card so
you can learn about the wine
you can learn about the tasting notes
the serving temperature the food pairing
sounds fun wine is a fun activity you
know because it's more than just like
enjoying a beverage it's it's learning
it's culture
it's it's got all the senses you know
pretty
it's complicated you can go as deep or
as surface as you want and bright cellar
gives you that option to make
a paint of apple and wood right a hint
of bob ganoosh
that's my favorite accent and you can
get as involved and as fun as you want
with
a bright cellar you can experience it
all you can host a virtual or regular
tasting with friends
cook a meal based on the wine education
cards and the wine you are drinking
date night idea drinking
like the french and pair it with the
fancy
how do you say that go ahead ela how do
you say that chartering beard
shirt
here's the deal we got a good deal for
y'all if you want to try this out
and you should for our listeners only we
are giving you 50
off your first six bottles orders
if you order from bright sellers yeah i
mean fifty percent all those go
by going to brightsellers.com h3
that's bright sellers c e l
l a r s dot com backslash h3
you can take their seven question quiz
get your wine match and receive 50
off your first six bottle orders get
your wine passport
try wines from all over the world by
heading to
brightsellers.com h3 and get
50 percent off your first box
of brightsellers wine listen
i hate to break the bad news to you but
some of you
are gonna have to confront this fact two
out of three men
will experience some form of hair loss
by the time they are 35
that's more than 50 million people in
the u.s suffering from male
pattern baldness we hate male pattern
boneless
we don't it's not fair it's not fair to
us men we deal with so much [ __ ] in our
life
all of a sudden you're telling me around
35 the hair leaves my head
and starts growing out my [ __ ] ass
and ears where's the justice in that
you think i haven't lived a hard enough
life up to 35
bust in my ass to put food on the table
and now i got a haircut on my ears and
ass and off my head
try having a period every month
you're right i take it all back but
more than 50 million men in the u.s
suffer what are we gonna do about it
there are two only two fda approved
medicines that could prevent hair loss
and keeps offers both
keebs offers a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair convenient virtual doctor
consultations and medication delivered
straight to your door
every three months so you never have to
leave your home the low cost
it starts at just ten dollars per month
and keeps offers the generic
version of the medicines you get
discreet packaging and proven results
keeps has five star reviews and that's
more than any of its competitors these
guys are
the real deal prevention is key
treatment can take four to six
months to see results so act fast and
stay vigilant
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss
go to k-e-e-p-s dot com
h3 to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash h3 to get your first month
for free
keeps k-e-e-p-s dot com slash h3
too often we are choosing between
quality and a fair price
with harry's razors you don't have to
choose because you're getting
award-winning blades
at factory direct prices people do i
have to say it louder
listen when i got harry's razors blown
away
by the girth not the girth but like the
weight of the hand though
the clean of the blade i mean this is
top level
stuff folks let's be honest i don't
shave that much but i shaved the back of
my neck
when i'm in the shower you got to clean
that up you know it took me the whole
life for started cleaning my neck i
always hated this [ __ ] you get
some people are blessed with a good
neckline i'm not one of them
if i'd if i didn't shave this this [ __ ]
would connect to my back
i look like a [ __ ] ape but luckily
i've got harry's razors
i know you use razors you clean up yeah
can i ask you a question
have you ever shaved your ankle just
where it shows
yeah okay i wasn't sure yeah definitely
that's something i learned on tick tock
about girl oh that's so did you know
that women just shave their ankles
well it's not like a regular thing but
i've definitely done that
yeah yeah did you know this about guys
this is one of the things i saw on tick
tock again guys pee
on [ __ ] stains in the toilet to clean it
i feel like i did know that you did done
that yeah
it's a power voice it grosses me out but
i can't help it
the only thing i avoid doing that in
public stall because it's like that's
yeah i don't want to piss on someone
else's [ __ ]
i can do it on my own but not someone
else's
that's like seinfeld down joke you don't
want
you don't want your boys mixing in with
someone else's voice
no anyway about harry's
for a limited time harry's is offering
their starter set
plus free body wash for just three
dollars harrys.com
h3 they delivered straight to your house
two dollars per refill you know these
blades are quality they have bought
their own factory in germany
they own every step of the manufacturing
process come on
are you kidding oh yeah get in they've
got the simple ergonomic design with
five
sharp blades they source the steel from
sweden they manufacture it in
world-class
factories they get it all your [ __ ]
doors just so you can shave your [ __ ]
ankles before you go out okay
but you got those ankles looking good as
hell
they got a 100 quality guarantee and
they stand behind the quality of the
blade so much
that they have that 100 money-back
guarantee
at harry's dot com h3 for a limited time
harry's has an exclusive offer just for
our listeners new customers can get
harry's starter set
and a free body wash for just three
dollars at harry's dot com
slash slash h3 that's over
sixteen dollars a value for just three
dollars you'll get five blade razor
weighted handle foam shave gel a travel
cover
a travel size body wash what a freaking
deal dude but you better act while
supplies last
while supplies last so hurry on over to
harrys.com
h3 to redeem your offer thank you guys
and we are back ian
do you want to set us up here a little
bit about the the uh
venture we're about to take
sure uh so this segment
is uh dubbed clickbait couture
very clever isn't that doesn't that what
is it clickbait yeah what is clickbait
couture
interesting well i'm so glad you asked
because
that's what we're going to be talking
about today so what set this off is the
if you open that imager uh gallery
that the first picture is what
i recognize this this was uh the uh
louis vuitton
recently right this was just happened
and everyone was kind of clowning on it
yeah virgil uh put that together um
for their fall winter campaign you
wouldn't wear this
well that's kind of what i kind of want
to do with everybody is we play a little
game of like hot or not
with all these pieces in here it's the
idea that
these designers make something that is
so
outlandish because now we all are just
kind of aware of it and then if you go
look at the rest of the collection it's
not like this
right it's like basically it's
click-baiting
into checking out their fashion it's
like high high level click bait
so that's true i kind of like that i
mean that's smart though i mean people
do that in the business world where they
make one statement piece right to pull
people in
good attention but i gotta say this
piece on the right is kind of fired the
one on the left looks kind of dumb
i totally agree with you the one on the
right the left like
what i don't know it doesn't
yeah it's just the new year cubicle and
like not
the one on the right is like that's
legit jacket bro i would zip that on
i mean how much do you think that jacket
well they probably aren't for sale but
because they probably made like one i
mean just probably just one of one right
yeah i couldn't find a price on those
ones i mean the execution is good i
think
you know the one on the left i feel like
i could make that
like in fifth grade anyway so that
so that's virgil so what do you got is
it is it hot or not
i would say the one on the right is hot
but the one on the left
i don't like i know he was getting
clowned on a lot but i think it's
it is hot on the right hot i didn't see
the one on the right
was that all i kept seeing was the one
on the left so i guess
because it looks so silly that's the one
that
is so controversial he was like damn it
i knew i shouldn't have put that piece
out
all the other less of the collection is
awesome yeah i mean it's interesting i
like the piece on the right
this one i've seen this one before as
well oh was this all the way
yeah this was balenciaga retail thirteen
hundred dollars i hate this [ __ ]
shirt i hate it i hated it from the
second i laid eyes on it
i've seen it before i knew it i knew it
was gonna be balenciaga
it's so [ __ ] dumb i literally hate
everything about it it's thirteen
hundred dollars
i know that like um they're taking the
piss but
i still hate it so
it definitely worked that was one of the
bigger ones here though that like that
that had the effect that they were
looking for it was
everywhere but like at the end of the
day
now we immediately knew it are you
really going to balenciaga and shopping
after you see this
maybe i don't know but they i guess it's
what ian is saying they got everyone
talking about them
maybe they are i don't know i tried to
talk evil into making something like
this
recently and you said no mine
you don't think i'm virgil well good
thing we got some we got some pitches
for you later so
okay great good good good so this is not
hot we're verdict not hot
oh yeah double no this is the worst
thing i literally hate it
this one who made this one jimmy jeremy
scott oh
[ __ ] yeah this is i don't like this
at all it's kind of funny
we heart our customers free pickup and
delivery i kind of like oh i believe
this one uh for 800 i think
oh that's kind of reasonable like in a
weird way for a runway
statement piece you like the
hanger hat i don't like the hanger hat i
think
we didn't need that part but it looks
like one of those goofy like
joke like an arrow through the head to
be honest it looks like a costume you
could get on amazon
for halloween exactly yeah but also you
gotta wear an outfit underneath
it's pretty funny is the dress part of
it or does
the dress choose your own adventure i
don't know
ian you're the expert wait what was that
is the dress come with the outfit or is
that a separate thing
the dress underneath i think it's
separate
what do you think of the little stock
that's pretty expensive then the sock
bag
the sock bag i like it's pretty funny
yeah the sock bag i like i'm gonna vote
hot on this one though
okay you're voting hot
yeah i think do you want to know my
honest truth i've watched top
fashion designer with ila like every
season
and i feel like it's all such dog [ __ ]
like i'll watch something down the
runway and all the judges are like oh
we love it and i'm like what like
i just don't understand high fashion or
profession like i honestly can't say
i i honestly can't say excuse me
third gang oh god i gotta slow down the
coffee
had like two cups charged hard
um okay if you guys say it's hot then
i'll believe you i mean
i don't know does that
what makes it hot
i mean i like the idea and also
it's still pretty surprisingly wearable
and
excuse me wearable she has an anger on
her head
well you don't have to put the hanger on
the hat i'm talking about the dress and
the
and the purse the dress is not part of
the look i'm looking at it as i look
whatever it's you buy the two layers i
don't know
okay apparently you guys i'm i'm i'm i'm
lukewarm on it
all right okay i don't think we have a
lukewarm sound you know what [ __ ] it i
don't like it i'm out okay
bye that's not hot that's not hot
okay now we're talking what do we have a
couple more collections
here yeah trash it's just called trash
dress
again this is the kind of court tour
which i don't get it like people i don't
like
people will look at a [ __ ] see what i
don't like here
is literally like this kind of
silhouette is whatever i've seen it a
million times it's
not that interesting to me and i feel
like katy perry would totally wear it
and i would hate it
trash on trash a little bit repetitive
thing i'm just kidding i don't hate her
um yeah this is the kind of thing that i
would see on like
um top fashion designer human project
project runway yeah i don't know i'm
like what are you doing and then every
and then all the judges go oh my god i
love
it's like oh and i'd be like i don't
understand what everybody sees that i
don't it's just like a different
language i don't know what i'm looking
at
no it looks dumb it's bad it's stupid
also it's obvious it's like okay trash
that's why i like the other one i feel
like
it's still kind of flattering too
flattering yeah it's just a see-through
bag
well like the shoulder part i don't know
it's pretty
clever it's just like
it's like we get it it's like they're
just trying it's like everyone
they've everyone's done everything so
now they're doing all this outrageous
stupid [ __ ] that's true that is part of
what happens when you're
a fashion designer they've probably all
of them they've done everything already
so how do you still make something new
you know if you go to the the next photo
too it's kind of in the similar um
theme which i guess i appreciate that
it's all linked
i guess it's the raiden hat
from mortal kombat
i mean the dress is kind of cool
oh it's like garbage bags right the bag
is awesome i think the dress is garbage
bags like two-ton garbage bags or
whatever
it's supposed to look like it i'm sure
it's actually expensive fabric
yeah it's like italian [ __ ] sweat
leather
i think that bag is awesome yeah the bag
is
cool i guess i don't know like again
it's like what am i okay cool
it's like is it if i saw someone wearing
this down the street i'd be like what
the [ __ ] is wrong with her
i mean you do only wear a t-shirt and
shorts
like everything i'll stop you know i
have a good taste in fashion you know
i have a good sense of fashion
admit it right now you do but
give them a little bit of a it's a
little try hard i know they're on the
runway though
but i mean god what are we doing here
yeah it's a little try hard
the hat how about here's an idea
untie the ribbon take one of these
garbage bags off and throw your outfit
in it
no i think the hat is try hard
i'll agree with you on that one also
what does it say about her that she's
trash
like she's got the lid on her head she's
trash she's in the garbage can
she is oscar the grouch yeah
garbage it's better than this one this
one i hate yeah this silhouette is so
boring
also it invokes like image like feelings
of like
an empty lot full of trash like on the
side of the road like just
it evokes like really negative feelings
looking at it you know
um mcdonald's chic anyone
this is all by jeremy scott the last
couple so he's kind of like the meme guy
you know on the runway it seems so this
is like mcdonald's
chic clearly
well i actually like the dress i like
the dress the hat
and wear the dress for sure yeah the
dress is really nice i like the dress
i don't like the hat and i don't like
the background that's the thing about
the runaway i mean you're not you don't
necessarily take it literally and wear
it on the street but you
take just the dress you can wear right
i mean i know yeah the bag is the item
that
went to retail and uh that's sold out
of course it did you know how much they
said everyone loves mcdonald's
yeah it's sold for uh 12.65
i wonder how many they made you know
12.65 like i i'm so curious about
quantities on these really high-end
items i just i have no idea is there a
thousand is it 500 is it 10
000. you know i just i'm dying to know
how much these they sell
so 100 000 i mean i don't know i have no
idea because like louis vuitton does
like billions of dollars a year
so they're selling ungodly amounts of
this [ __ ]
yeah i mean it's also worldwide you know
i mean it looks like a really nice bag
i'm not gonna hate on that
jeremy scott is really talented i know
some of his work i'll fight him what
does he look like
let's see what jeremy's causing i don't
like
jeremy scott let's see what it looks
like i mean i like that he makes super
creative
stuff ooh oh bro you really walk around
like that
we don't like him you don't like him
is this what you want me to dress like
so that i could tell the world that i
have a good fashion
sense probably
okay shout out jeremy scott shout out to
his family he looks like the shout out
to your family guy
shout out to his family
okay he's out there doing his thing god
bless him
the next one is a is an all-star in
in the click bait realm i think the dhl
this has got to be oh so veterans is
known for taking the piss out of
everyone
like literally and it's i mean i know
they're joking but people still buy it
and then wear it
literally it's just a straight up dhl
shirt like people will think you work
for dhl
bedaments retail 261 dollars it's a
vet bond oh it's called provost vetmon
yeah what is the language it's french
it's french
i think oh so meta
i can't i can't do it
it's funny wait i mean who's the joke on
though the people buying it
kind of they're like i dare you to buy
this shirt for 261 dollars
idiot and wear and look like a dhl's
worker
i know you know meanwhile dhl who's like
kind of the shittiest carrier of all of
them
like it's not even like a good one you
know it's okay
it's like the [ __ ] you get from china
that you need to sign for and you're not
quite sure if it's gonna arrive or not
and then
and you know dhl is like why are we
doing this collab but okay you're paying
me like a million dollars so yes
wait wait wait one of the top
designer brands in the world wants to
collab with dhl okay
they're like hi can we talk to your head
of collaborations they're like we just
send [ __ ]
over from china
the next uh three photos are also from
them
at a recent uh show they put it on
at a mcdonald's this yeah their photos
on vitamins are also like
super weird so what is it has like huge
shoulder pads
i kind of like this one i'm not gonna
lie french writer i kinda like them
they make really funny stuff it's
outside of mcdonald's and then you've
got this guy walking after him like
he's up to something i do like this
jacket
and those guys
next who's this [ __ ] that's the guy
behind him
so this guy's also invest so it's like
an extremely oversized dress shirt
with a what does the tag say is that
part of the shirt i think it says
capitalism
hello
this piece is horrible i hate it so much
wait is the tie on part of it too ian is
it all just like printed on there
i don't think the tie is printed on
there
like it might be sewn on there or
something i think it's a real tie
okay i wasn't sure because i never know
with them
i just hate at the size it's like so
enormous
also hello capitalism is like cool dude
awesome
i'm 14 this is deep i don't like it
pretty epic
i can hear your fanny and god bless oh
he's wearing sandals stop
elo say something i hate the sandals
i do not get that i do not approve you
can't give them a pass on that [ __ ]
it's like they're trying to make the
ugliest yeah
yeah and people still buy it
so they did this like big collab with
star wars just because he's wearing a
star wars hat and i saw it was all on
sale
at the end of the year just so you know
so people didn't buy that one
yeah and super expensive god those
sandals are something else bro
like if you saw him walking down the
street you'd be like oh my god he's in a
ten thousand dollar outfit or you'd be
like this guy's a weirdo
like oh wow this guy is fashionably like
this guy's [ __ ]
really weird guy but i feel like that's
the thing for people who are
so in the fashion like
the technically normal good stuff are
too boring for them
so right they have to be like they're
speaking
like a private language that only they
speak so like anyone who knows will be
like
oh that guy knows you know what i mean
it's like a private little nod
this the model's just like what the [ __ ]
that's not hot so more mcdonald's shoots
um
this shirt's fine i'll probably get it
but again are you sure this isn't
printed on i feel like this is printed
on the shirt ian
why it fits the motion because
because that's what would put the shirt
over
the edge of being absurd that they would
make you got to find the
the picture on their website um i
promise you it's not
it's it's he's wearing it well this is a
normal shirt then
well it's not look at the silhouette
it's not that bad it's like a nice shirt
so you like it or you don't i do like it
okay yeah
yeah i like this shirt that's hot it's
not that but how is this click
it's not really clickbaity it's just a
short the whole concept i guess of them
looking like
what would you call it like a mcdonald's
officer
security officer
okay this is [ __ ] weird for sure this
one is weird
no that's the kind of stuff rick owens i
don't really
okay so rick owens the stuff before i
kind of enjoy
it it puts a smile on my face it's like
is that a real person on her back it
looks like it oh god
this is just okay so what i thought at
first was that it was like a life
like looking backpack and i was like
that's cool actually but it's a real
person so i mean
that makes it worse in my opinion just
to double back the the uh
security guy it's not printed on the
shirt oh yeah thank you for the
clarification
i think i know my stuff just checking
you know so what is this he's selling a
harness like what is he selling exactly
and she's a harness for a person
yeah so this is not hot
i don't like it we don't like it ian you
want to weigh in or not
uh not hot maybe the next one
ah that's not hot what the [ __ ]
so this one is basically the front
version i hate it
hold on don't rush to judgment
i hate it rick owen with the hair too
why is it so
so uh you know when you flip a backpack
front way so she basically did that but
her ass is about one inch
from her nose i hate it but again what
are you selling a strap
are you selling me a human being
statement
what do you do you like this one zach
it's more like a 69 than a fashion
statement
zach would love to wear this on a hot
that was a really loud diarrhea sound
with a nice echo reverb thank you zach
hate it this is what i'm saying
everybody's trying so hard it's like
they stopped that was like old news to
me i feel like that would have been done
in like
10 years ago i don't think this was ever
cool that's my point is like
just stop
oh my god okay this i hate
more than anything that's not hot
okay so it's like a giant onesie with
huge glove pieces
and you look good you you comment you're
the you're the expert
um the concept is kind of funny but it
doesn't look good on him i don't like
i don't like that open chest
i mean
what am i supposed to do with this
really isn't this a
like a fetish that we looked at one time
oh after dark
oh my god oh you're totally right there
is a net fetish
okay so they're doing runways for knit
fetishes now i mean how niche are we
getting
i wonder if they even know about the
fetish i think they're just
yeah they might be in they're making a
mistake they might not know i mean it's
a
pretty it's a pretty close-knit
community
me daddy i don't like this
i hate it so much the big hands give me
anxiety yeah i hate it
like the hands are so big i just [ __ ]
hate it bruh
no no no no so here's another one a knit
fetish no oh this is so net fetish no no
that's what theodore says again
literally hate it i just don't like it
it's not even aesthetically pleasing the
big hands give me
anxiety ah that's not hot
right
[Music]
oh my god got that roger rabbit villain
vibes
[Music]
that's a really good observation i hate
it i mean i hate it
also i hate this i don't hate it as much
as that at once
if we're right this is the worst thing
ever yeah this is probably my least
favorite
yeah it's like at least it's kind of
cool
how they put it together right that's
true technically it's impressive
i'm curious what the [ __ ] is it because
it's like looks like 2d
that's pretty impressive but that's
about it
oh there's 13 more images let's go oh my
god what this isn't real
what is this ian yeah this is real
a designer named sam kim from uh okay
fashion weekend 22. this is def this is
good it looks like tom segura in there
so this is this is my favorite one it's
trash bags
are inflated airbags and um there's one
for each arm and one for each leg this
is
fire oh god
yeah there must be a fan or something
because it's staying at fleso inflated
you know
i hate it it's getting steamy oh you
know we should do ella we should get
mexican today
because i can do keto mexican we haven't
ordered out okay
i think you're gonna work on your planks
yes
okay i'm so [ __ ]
hungry looking at this daddy in the
garbage bag
this one i really like because it's like
because i'll tell you why
it's so [ __ ] dumb you know that
they're not trying
it's literally just like this is so
[ __ ] dumb it's
actually funny that's not even debate
like
yeah i'm gonna cruise around in this
yeah no one is really
expecting that also i love the model he
used it looks like tom segura like it's
not some high-end
it's just a dude and a queen i mean god
bless all inclusive
all right next we have um by the same
designers
it looks like a red like a mangas right
a manga character a little bit
so this is like a he's like inflatable
chic like pool floaty chic
i just want to say inflatable it's not
that new
yeah this is a different designer
for this one i mean okay this is this
one i hate
i hate it so much because they didn't do
anything she's literally just holding a
pool inflatable and put her head through
it and literally everybody's standing
here like oh
uh interesting they're like looking at
it like there's there's nothing that
doesn't mean anything there's
she's holding a pool a pool a kiddie
pool and her head is through it there's
nothing to analyze or sit there and
ponder it's just [ __ ] stupid
right thank you
oh that's that's what i'm saying
i just feel like
the whole floaty shake is so been done
like a million times it's
just like we get it someone makes the
statement once and then
we all move on it's not hot it's not new
it's not cool
get your [ __ ] head out of your ass
and start designing yeah that's not hot
this one i love of course balenciaga yet
again hits with the ikea bag
for 2145
i'm assuming it's not made of plastic
like the ikea bag
no it's not it's probably like a leather
this was actually designed by the guy
who
does all of the ventman stuff demna it's
the same
same guy hi what do you do yeah i design
a
[ __ ] [ __ ] for people i just
design uh expensive ikea bags
yeah so two thousand retails pretty
pretty good
were they trying to make it look like an
ikea bag are you just goofing on them
i mean that that was the observation
everyone made i i even ikea
made like a response i mean clearly i
would not buy that but that's how much
balenciaga costs
you know funny though oh god what the f
oh oh my god look at this picture on the
right wait what
is that related 500
9-foot extendo pants
is this the jeans on the right yeah is
that a real photo yeah
yeah those are the jeans what the [ __ ]
bro yeah exactly i'm just thinking it
reminded me of all retreats
we got to buy these for all of our
dreams why is it so skinny
are you supposed to roll them up or
something like super big
that's what they say yeah what would
that even look like
i can find a picture quick they're only
500 bucks by the way because that's like
three dreams
i mean jeans are like over a hundred
dollars easy let's say 150 bucks for a
nice pair of jeans
that's like three jeans together so if
you do
times three that's 450 that's barely
more than an ordinary amount of jeans
what is this product
what the [ __ ] like five hundred dollars
like they're trying to make it
accessible you know what i mean
like i just want everyday people to be
able to buy these
[Music]
this is nightmarish in my opinion it
makes me anxious yeah i hate it
i sent you the picture of them rolled up
oh okay
so that makes more that definitely makes
more sense it's like
it's a yeah
that makes a lot more sense than this
yeah
that's kind of funny yeah it looks crazy
but it makes sense as like a look
sharpay ass pants
fascinating yeah chanel uh oh what
chanel up to a boomerang
a [ __ ] boomerang why the [ __ ] was
janelle boomerang
fifteen hundred dollars man chanel is
one of those brands
their clothes is really nice but it is
so
expensive bro oh my god everyone what is
this supposed to be it's a boomerang
like a home decoration or what
it's a boomerang what is a boomerang you
toss it
well like trisha bought like a chanel
bird cage
that's a purse though oh it's a purse
yeah
boomerang's kind of hype you use it for
self-defense
they got a a decent amount of backlash
for this too
for kind of using indigenous australian
culture for like this big expensive
fashion item it's [ __ ] boomerang bro
that shit's like you can't
i mean the boomerang i feel like has
gone mainstream at this point
i don't think i didn't know that people
didn't yeah
boomerangs are like come on boomerang's
been in mainstream
culture for a long time now i didn't
know that it was
some indigenous thing chanel's two
thousand dollar boomerang criticized for
humiliating indigenous
australian culture i mean humiliating
i'm not going to tell them how to feel
but
i'm sure they were like what people are
mad about the boomerang now
it's a pretty weird product i don't get
it it's a weird product it's like you
didn't have to make this for sure
sometimes in the design room people are
like okay we just need something
totally off the wall for this drop
boomerang
okay up next we've got balenciaga back
at it again
see i like these shoes this is cool
these shoes are cool because they're
colorful
they're weird they look super different
it's obviously very functional
and i've never seen a shoe like that
that being said they are four thousand
two hundred dollars
that's like how they're kind of
described online but like yeah i mean
this is a product that i think is really
cool yeah
you know there's no legos though come on
dan you know what they mean
i know what a lego is i don't i'm not
seeing anything like that they're called
that's all i'm saying okay all right
let's not get into that over soon
this is a paper bag made of leather
three hundred dollars hmm as a bag
uh what i don't like it because like i
don't want to just carry a bag like that
yeah
also like why do you want to look see
this is stupid i'll tell you why
you're trying to look poor
who wants to carry around a paper bag i
get it you made leather that looks like
a paper bag that's impressive god bless
whatever
i'm not buying that nobody should buy
that period
it's a good deal though
seem worse okay hermes
leather horse 133 800 dollars
yeah it's just a big leather horse i
don't like it it's hideous
yeah it's like a desecration it's like
yeah they say uh kosher
you shouldn't use the milk of the animal
with the animal because it's an insult
to the animal
this is a deck secretion you're using
the leather i know leather is from cows
but still they're kind of related so
they're using the leather from the cows
to desecrate a [ __ ]
the likeness of a horse it just doesn't
seem right
good they drive a hard bargain though at
140 000.
destroyed sneakers
that's kind of funny i kind of like this
one
but like i like this if it actually
doesn't fall apart which i doubt it
would
you know what i mean it's built to last
i'm assuming at 1400
yeah destroyed sneakers
some people like that look i don't know
but you know people like the dirty
sneaker look like
gucci was selling dirty sneakers i i
think last year
that was like what was in
this is odd it's a jacket
it's kind of weirding me out i don't
like it i mean that
the execution is cool it's impressive
but
i just don't like the hands
yeah that's an attention getter i mean
like everybody's gonna be staring at
your ass with that thing on
1200 bucks i don't know
i'm all i i don't know how to feel about
this but mostly i feel negative about it
the supreme rip brick i love the supreme
brick because
this was a very specific statement by
supreme okay
because supreme is very self-aware and
they're basically like we can sell you a
[ __ ] brick
and they did yeah i mean
it's almost like a statement that's
being thrown around like there's
they can put their logo on anything and
people will buy it
but they can't sell you a brick and then
they did
but also they only sold it for 30 bucks
which i know it's a lot for a brick but
it's not like they're selling it for a
thousand bucks
and i i think that's really important
for the picture to be cool
because if they were signing it for a
thousand that's kind of annoying
yeah so
i think people don't realize that
supreme they think of supreme as
first of all it is expensive but the
resale market is where it can get really
expensive
if you can get it on their website
before it sells out the prices are not
as bad as you would think
maybe just found it on stockx 250 bucks
yeah you guys want it no i'm not
interested in the supreme brick but i'm
just saying i would buy it for 30 bucks
i've always wanted one of those yeah
it's collectible i mean it's a record
piece
it's a cool statement yeah i i like the
supreme break like a piece of history
now
yeah i like the supreme brick the moment
it came out
ridiculously high fashion item oh the
game showed up
yeah when i googled that i was very
surprised
that's funny this isn't edited no it's
not i checked on my phone too
so let's see what came up uh some kind
of
face mask a kfc hoodie and pants
and again what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
what oh my god are you serious this
show's up
hold on i'm typing ridiculously high
fast give it a shot oh yeah i'm gonna do
it you're [ __ ] with me
just high fashion or items ridiculous
high fashion
items okay that's what i typed i don't
see ads
i'm not getting that shopping ad images
do i have block on or something yeah who
cares
i agree with them by the way the gatsby
is ridiculously high fashion
all right so that was fun i mean i've
learned
a lot overall i always
appreciate most of them because i still
think it's
it's like a form of art and they're
making a statement
spicing up the the fashion world because
i mean if that's all you do i'm sure it
gets so repetitive
you know we're kind of new to like
making clothes
i think you're you're right in that it's
like they have this imagine after 20
years of making clothes you're like
so is it like this where they have like
a whole collection and then one of the
items is just there for a gag
or is the whole collection just like all
gab well
it depends not that i know that much too
i'm just saying based on what i think i
know
um i feel like it depends also if you're
looking at like couture runway or
like couture is not really meant for you
to even wear necessarily
but um even in like let's say
nakutu just a runway like louis vuitton
runway
i think they do probably just make a
couple that are mostly statement pieces
and not necessarily like
this is gonna be your daily jacket you
know
i'm gonna just walk out i i i think that
um
oh my cat's ass is in the way yeah
[Music]
uh i think you know maybe it's time
teddy fresh could get in on some of this
yep i love it high fashion stuff so
uh we each have have a pitch for you
guys
everyone's got one fantastic video
so all right let me watch this video so
it's all in here first up is zach
oh my goodness so you guys went to the
new office and filmed this right
our empty office that we have we're
waiting on the plans yes sir
this is zach yes sir the fat bird
what this is awesome this is
better than most the [ __ ] i saw on there
that's pretty awesome
like if this went down the if this was
on that list i would be like i like this
one
yep wow
[Music]
this is great i love the fabric i think
that's hot
so we refresh people's memory on what
the fat burns oh there's little turds on
it
oh there it is so the fat burger we
learned is when you're
what happens when you flush baby wipes
down the drain none of them are
flushable some of them say flush with a
lot they get stuck
in the sewer the sewage system and
blocks the whole [ __ ] cities you know
sewage and they have to
drill it out it's called a fat burg
creating the sewage monsters
damn that's really good this is this uh
that that's the
this piece this piece has little
little poopies on it um features little
poopies
little wet wipes that you know authentic
that was beautiful yeah
and um little sewage rats on the
shoulder pads
okay let me see do you have any flat
shots of this that i can take a closer
look at the details
yeah i'll send you one second i
personally love
this and i'm not saying that if this was
on that if this was made by vetements or
some other oh i gotta say it's pretty
flattering i think zach looks good in it
i agree it is it's a good silhouette
it's a good silhouette with the nail
polish still
it's well conceived i mean really truly
hi this is hot
news teddy fresh drop what do you think
yeah teddy fresh [ __ ] it yeah let's tell
it
whoa all right we've got dan as the
forehead diamond
oh no [ __ ] way oh my god
yo this is this is good wait this
is better than my god oh oh no
[Music]
spiderman memes you gotta have it in
there
oh my goodness this
is amazing amazing you guys
i could totally see jeremy scott do this
look
i'm once again floored
i don't know if you expected us to not
like people but i actually i
genuinely love this like once again if
this was made by jeremy scott or
venomous or something i'd be like that's
my favorite on the list yeah
and knowing the inspiration too it's
like oh bet you think that's a big
diamond wait to see my outfit
damn good job modeling yeah crush that
when you put the eyes in front of your
head i was like oh wait wait
wait you know it's like
when the sometimes the designers have
these really dramatic things where the
dress falls i felt like that was yeah
called a runaway moment yeah you had a
runway moment when the eyes went
over your head i'm trying to find your
runway moment again
oh bro get out of here dan you were born
for this
[Music]
oh my goodness that's amazing
oh my god i can't
these are so [ __ ] good
holy [ __ ]
that's amazing you know in project
runway there's usually like
kind of like a challenge like this and
then the winner
gets to actually the the winner look
gets to actually be manufactured and
sold on some website
yeah they sell it on like amazon or like
something terrible something terrible
yeah
but um this reminds me of that well what
are you saying
then i'm wondering if we should pick a
logan and make it
teddy fresh forehead diamond cardboard
get your card
for her yo i am so impressed
i am holy [ __ ] okay wow
wow
i couldn't choose between the two i love
them both so much
next up we have
the power of shungai now ian i know you
hold shungite near and uh what do you
say how
near and dear so this is the power it's
a dead meme
don't care what's dead about it it's
vibra look at it it's vibrant and
humming right now as well
it looks very current very cyber truck
cavaliers here
let's go i'm in i bought a whole bunch
of water
oh wow oh your hands are your shoulders
are heads are those your hands or your
shoulder blades
my shoulders are the galaxy brain oh
dude you have galaxy brain
shoulders anybody know what shungite is
oh my god this is magical oh
no
[Music]
honestly this could be a great runway
not even
joking i feel so at peace
wow speechless now this is next level
current stuff
not the [ __ ] blow up looks that's
been done like
early 2000s probably i don't know i am
floored
floored i am floored oh that shungite
look was so peaceful i want that
the galaxy brain shoulders and like the
curves
angles we could reimagine that for teddy
fresh
so ian you thought we were going to come
out here and hate all these and be like
oh we don't think that's good for teddy
fish i'm sorry but i'm picking up this
whole line
yo this is such a powerful moment
i was feeling it oh my god you became
shungite
this is so insane bro i can't believe
what i'm seeing
a little pretzel look protects against
frequencies and unwanted frequencies
that may be traveling in the air
holy [ __ ]
bruh oh my god each one gets better
oh god wait till we got one more to go
whoa
uh first of all first of all thank you
for being updated because
i know that my wikifeed score is in flux
a lot
and this one is he pulled it yesterday
yeah thank you i appreciate that it's
updated
who's in this one baby
didn't recognize the body
so abs looks to be my foot the perfect
foot
i know it's my focus the score obviously
i love that the score is so recognizable
like you immediately know
giant [ __ ] butt nails
this is something else entirely
how is this happening so
ethan has three toes well it's an
interpreter oh
wait no here's the nails yeah the
shoulders
yeah come on these are too fast i need
to enjoy this for longer
i feel like can i be honest this content
is way too good to just be put bearing
in the middle of our podcast
this is next level content right here
[Laughter]
what happened to all these costumes ian
where are they dan has much of it's
actually in my car outside
because i wonder if we can do something
with it on friday i mean it's just
it's so good but it's a lot of like
putting on taking off
maybe when we finally move into the new
office we can all
ascend you know what i mean yeah well
we're keeping them so oh
ian i have some behind the scenes
footage
you do good nice i want that i need that
in my life because this is the best
thing i've ever seen so impressive
guys
i feel like my favorite part about this
one is the sign i don't know why
it's like so it's so recognizable and
simple i
immediately knew what it was
it's powerful man i could easily see
this selling for ten thousand dollars on
vitamins it looks like a dark souls
villain
right for sure it does yeah
[Music]
work it work it work it
work it people we love it we love it
take a bow take an absolute bow people
wow
wow take a bow i feel like we don't
deserve this good content
so wait there's something good cheesy
this is when we were trying to do the
walking
now step to the dead like four steps
okay
one two three now a little forward
just a little bit now right there great
now stop no
you're walking like a thumb maybe
[Applause]
ian says part of ian's notes here is
brutally rejects us and saying it's not
good
sorry bro dan wrote that oh dan
i thought that's how it would go is you
know maybe you're like
these this is the best hi that is the
single best high fashion show i've ever
seen
and i'm not just saying that all that
[ __ ] i just saw in the
before leading up to this is trash old
[ __ ] news ian you need to become a
high fashion designer bro you just
ascended
you this work is too menial for you
[Music]
uh i also got to give some credit to sam
who helped me with a lot of things
yeah you know sam is basically a
full-time employee at this point
we gotta just hire her i know should we
just hire sam
i i'm screwing with your sleep schedule
when i've run it yeah
i need you to paper mache a giant thumb
that's awesome she's up for it i mean
shout out to sam the mystery girl by the
way we should love her
wow it's gone the wild card right the
wild card shout out to her family so ian
can we hire you again on teddy fresh
yeah well uh these you know these uh
pieces range from you know
five to 25 million
so maybe we can work something out
um very high level very high level
i got to give a big shout out to you ian
i mean i was blown away that's amazing
yeah i'm blown away i'm blown away this
is the greatest thing i've ever seen i
mean i just
i feel like this video was not long
enough it makes me so sad that um
we had to do this remote because i would
have loved to
even be there and shoot even more about
it which is your favorite
um the fatberg is just perfect
the eye is perfect the diamond eye is
perfect like dan worked it and there was
such a runway moment with the eyes
yeah also the execution on the diamond
like the shiny foil is just fantastic i
mean
get out look at this look at this runway
moment
put it in there don't do it don't do it
yeah
no he didn't do it for me that one i
keep missing the runway moment
oh and he puts his neck up and [ __ ] like
that next level runway moment
the shungite was just it hit so hard and
so powerful
i felt like the end the negative energy
waves were being blocked that i really
did
[Music]
anybody know what shanghai the foot
i mean all give praise to the perfect
fight you know what i mean
yeah a b working it
those giant the nails for shoulders
again you went over the top you didn't
have to do it but you did it
anyway why'd you do it to him
had to that's why
wow blown away
incredible work
thank you to my models who crushed it
did a good job dan has dan has a future
in runway walking
definitely yeah dan you've got you
definitely got an honorable mention on
that
working that [ __ ] that diamond look
which is the most accessible do you
think for a mainstream audience
to wear yeah that's so cute i feel like
uh the shun gut really
the shungite yeah i could see a dress
like that with heads on the shoulders
and like because i feel like we should
probably try to convert one of these to
a mainstream look
that's my hunch i i could see someone
wearing it if it was a little
um a little bit muddy yeah
what you mean with the shungite
what about the foot you weren't vibing
on the foot for mainstream look
i mean there's something there
it's not the big pile of [ __ ] covered
wipes
in the sewer that would i like i mean i
can't say i don't like that one
i'd basically just be selling a ghillie
suit though with [ __ ] on it
man i don't know how i follow that up
with anything
how long we've been going dan about an
hour and a half i'm going to wrap it up
i'm not going to follow this without
nothing follows this nothing
what other behind the same footage you
got
um i didn't get a lot because we didn't
have a lot of time but
i got us getting there putting on the
outfits
and i figured out maybe i get some more
from ian since he uh
since he made the outfits but i got zan
uh
zach zipping up the bodysuit and it
breaking on me immediately
that happens way too often man
that was your guys's first time being
all together in one room and
yeah pretty much how long yeah first
first time for me ever
yeah yeah all four of us how's the space
in there
i mean it's amazing it's so awesome to
have a place like that to uh well yeah i
mean that part's not awesome but um
just having that available you know in
the past if we wanted to do something
like that we'd have to find a warehouse
to rent and
speak and just like being able to be
like hey we'll just roll over there and
shoot this thing also the brick wall
look great like i mean it's a good
setting it doesn't feel like you're in
an office for sure
right i can't wait until it's the studio
it won't be never we got that we got
those buildings like six months ago at
this point
maybe even longer i don't know
yeah it was about six months when i
started
well we'll see you guys on friday thank
you for watching i really can't follow
this up with anything i just want to let
it sit it was that good i don't want to
touch it with anything
great job to all the models to the
designer
to sam she's like associate designer yes
to sam who's basically um
the secret beatle aka the unpaid
employee
you're the salary to play she's the
unsalaried employee
wow all right guys we'll see on friday
for after dark
live until then take care god bless
be safe peace and love
shout out for the island shout out to
the iron man
all right guys see you next time